on
Robotic snakes sound like the stuff of
nightmares.
But their limbless movements make them
good candidates for exploring land, sea
and air.
On a recent expedition Egypt. a robotics
team ran into trouble.
Their robo snake couldn't make its way
up sandy inclines.
"We're often as is interested in failures
of locomotive models as we are
success because the failures help us
understand some of the principles."
Meanwhile... a  physics team in Georgia was working out the biomechanics of snakes
on tilted sandy soils. "We thought to
yourself what's a very cool animal
that no one is looked at?" As it turned
out
robots aren't the only ones to have problems
with the sand. But one snake had no issues
ascending the steepest slopes
the Sidewinder rattlesnake. When
sidewinders sidewind
they're actually sending two waves down
their body: one in the horizontal plane
and one in the vertical plane. Where
these waves meet
determines which part of their bodies
move ahead in which stays stuck to the soil.
Their secret to tackling slopes? Increasing the proportion of their
bodies in contact with the sand
as the slope got steeper. It's harder
than it sounds.
After teaming up,
the researchers use what they learned from
the Sidewinders to improve the robot
snake.
Because the snakebot showed improvement
it meant that their understanding of
sidewinding mechanics was accurate
and now it has the skills to slither up
all the dunes in Egypt.